welcome back I'm joined by the talk TV
contributor Paula Rohn Adrian times
radio host Steve gamble makes his debut
on Piers Morgan I'm certain city great
to see you I got a new book out death
under a little Sky uh which is described
probably by you as gloriously
atmospheric no truly excellent debut and
other wonderful trip it's it's a totally
great book I haven't read it yet holiday
today and I will go and read it that's a
birthday present for you happy birthday
thank you 68 today isn't it that's my
hair did I read that wrong good to see
you let's talk about this this gender in
schools business right we talk a lot
about gender related things and some
people get bored with it but they're a
really important principles of stake
here what did you feel sister you're a
parent the idea that a child could be at
school
self-identifying with all that goes with
that with the full the school's full
knowledge and kind of cooperation if you
like and the parents wouldn't know what
do you think of that I think first of
all it's such a difficult area we talked
about a lot on our program as well today
um I feel sorry for teachers first of
all I don't know how you be a teacher in
this situation you know you come into
school a kid comes to you and says
um I might have been born a girl but I
think I'm a boy what do you do you want
to look after them you don't want them
to be bullied because I don't think you
don't tell the parents well I agree with
that I think in the end the only way
these things get settled is if people
talk openly about them that means
there's three people involved in this
there's the school the teacher there's
the kid and there's the parent right and
why wouldn't you just talk about this
stuff I've got a 14 year old and it is
very striking to me this type fluidity
non-binary stuff it's definitely there
it's there in the school a couple of
kids yeah but it's also it seems to me
like it's a it's Paula it does seem to
me like a craze right it seems like it's
a fad like it's the trendy thing now for
young people at school to go I'm
non-binary I'm gender fluid they're all
doing it right I mean there's a school
in Brighton which is the mecca for all
these things um where I think like one
in ten kids was identifying as
non-binary out of a thousand it was
ridiculous
um obviously they're not all I suspect
genuinely mainly non-binary they're just
going along with whatever it is and lost
in the wash will be the ones who've
really got gender dysphoria right so I I
have a problem with this as a parent of
four kids if I found out that a school
and teachers were deliberately hiding
information like the gender identities
supposedly of my kids I'd be furious
you'd be furious and you'd have a right
to be furious wouldn't you do you think
because absolutely we have to understand
and remember what it is a school is
supposed to do a school is supposed to
be there to look after our child and
Care our child it's essentially acting
as a parent when we're not and it's
supposed to be there to not only help
our child but to educate our child now I
do wonder what the message is that we
would be giving to a child if a child
came to you and said keep this a secret
don't tell my mum don't tell my dad and
as an adult you said okay I won't
that's that's not helpful either I agree
with that but why does the parent I mean
you're a parent we're all parents
it's the parent shop to know as well
because yeah but stay come on now you
know I was just I'd love to think I'm
the best parent in the whole world there
are going to be things about my child I
don't know if it's not actually that I
was struck by the Numbers the numbers of
schools well this was going on yeah I
was absolutely shocked when I read that
report this morning well it's seven out
of ten it's seven out of 10. they only
asked 150 schools so you can you can
judge about however you like but it's
quite a big thing as a parent I mean I'm
not a very amen we all can realize our
flaws was parenting about 14 year olds
how many times did you not tell your
parents things about you when you were
growing up
the kids feel like they've got a foil
yeah they've got someone who's in on
their thing right but this is
about their identity this is not like
they might be sneaking a cigarette but
you said you really believe Steve this
is about their Identity or is it just
about joining the club I think it's
about both of the kids in my experience
they experiment they're all over the
place particularly teenagers and I think
to a certain extent we've got to allow
them to express themselves you've got to
allowed to see where they are in the
world and we've all done it now I think
there is a a herd mentality in this area
but we've all experimented at various
times in our in our lives particularly
when we're young and you've got to give
them a certain amount of space to do
what do you think about what do you
think about self-identity which is now
this massive crisis really where
Nicholas sturgeon has to basically lose
her job as first Minister because she
just couldn't say what a woman is and
couldn't understand why people were
angry that a male rapist went to a
women's prison what do you feel about
the the concept of Limitless
self-identity see I think you can't
change biology I think it's really easy
for me as a man
people I think people can do what they
want with their lives but it's never
going to really harm my rights so
they're conflicts of Rights you have to
do this all the time in law there's the
rights of women there's the rights of
people who want to identify a certain
way it never clashes with my rights
because I'm a bloke people can say
whatever they like I don't need a safe
safe space I've not got any safe spaces
that to me is no it's all in this case
it's all about the infringement of
women's rights exactly Paul I want to
show you a video clip yes this is of a
uh a coach a weightlifting coach male
called RV silverberg
who decided that he would exploit this
was in Canada where the rules say that
anyone who self-identifies as a woman
could compete in the female category so
he was a male powerlifting coach who
then self-identified as a woman entered
the woman's powerlifting competition
yeah uh smashed the record obviously the
all-time record of 84 kgs or something
set by Anne Andres who was also
transgender a man who identified or male
identifies and competes as a woman and
he did it to prove a point about the
absurdity yes in sport especially yes
the absurdity of where Limitless
self-identity takes you yes it's absurd
and and of course when you look at that
extreme you are going to get the Absurd
of course you are and that when we are
are at the end of the episode we're also
not helping the people who actually do
want to identify that doesn't help them
either and so he was right actually I
think I do support him for doing that
because clearly we do need to work at
this we do need to understand what's
going on but shutting people out
shutting a parent out is not the answer
there's not a human right to to compete
in support and I think ultimately male
biology particularly through puberty
means you have a difference
and you can respect trans people and
their right to live a life but they
don't have a human right to compete in
female Sport and I think what we're
seeing now actually is a hardening you
know a lot of sporting bodies have just
recognized that that's a relatively
straight well let me ask you guys two
completely different questions right but
I want a straight answer simple answers
uh uh 10 years time
if you're still alive will King Charles
still be King Charles in other words
will there still be a monarchy that's
the easy answer yes yeah I agree yes
easy answer and in two and a half years
time well Richie sumac still be prime
minister no no really
I think you can just I'm not so sure I
think you can mount a case just about
that maybe the momentum is faintly
swinging back but even if he was
brilliant yes and even if you don't know
this stage in 1992 at this stage Neil
kinnick was further ahead had been ahead
in the polls longer than Kia stama he
was further ahead in the polls over the
Tories and the Tories eventually brought
in safe old John Major yes got a little
bit of cocky and safe all John Major
Nick tip you've got conservative MPS now
launching legal action